وهذا الملف محور مع الحدث مع زميل جمال
بدون جمال اهلا بك مساله العسكريه لطالما
اثرت الخلافات دخل حلف شمال الاطلسي الى
اي حد ساهمت الحرب الاوكرانيه في حل هذه
القضيه هذه من مفارقات هذه الحرب انها
فعلا احيت الحلف شمال الاطلسي واعطته هذه
الديناميه تتذكرين عندما هذا الحوار
الشهير للرئيس ايمانويل ماكرون عندما
نتحدث عن الموت الدماغي للحلف وقتها كان
هناك مشكل تصدع بين الاعضاء خصوصا تركيا
والتي كانت لها مشكله على مع اليونان ومع
فرنسا وقتها بالاضافه الى مساله الانفاق
العسكري لانها لم يكن هناك اجماع عليه على
هذه المساله كانت تثير دائما جدلا لان من
ينفق على الحفا الاطلسي تاريخيا هو
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ثلث الميزانيه
تقريبا دونالد ترامب في اجتماع بروكسيل
عام 2018 قال كان صارما وقال للاعضاء ضعوا
ايديكم في جيوبكم
اثنان في المئه من الناتج الداخلي الخام
لكل دوله ينبغي ان تصل اليه
في حدود 2024
وطلبه باربع في المئه بعد ذلك الان من
الايجابيات او مفارقات هذه الحرب ان تحركت
معظم الدول تحركت في اتجاه هذه النسبه
الانفاق اثنان في المئه كل الدول البلطيق
مثلا والدول المحاديه لروسيا وصلت الى هذا
الحد بولندا
بالاضافه ايضا الى فرنسا التي تقترب منها
سيتحقق في السنه المقبله هي تقريبا اكثر
من واحد فاصل خمسه في المئه المانيا ايضا
بمعنى ان مساله الانفاق تتحرك بشكل
بسبب هذه الحرب والخطر الذي استشعره الحلف
تحركت مساله الميزانيه
والان النقاش لم يعد حول 2% من الناتج
الداخلي الخام لكل دوله كسقف للانفاق
العسكري بل اصبح كارضيه فقط
بمعنى ان هذه النسبه سترتفع في السنوات
المقبله
هو السؤال الى اي حد سيواصل الحلف حلف
شمال الاطلسي دعم اوكرانيا عسكريا الى اي
حد ممكن ان يصل هذا الدعم على كل حال الان
سمعنا الامين العام شمال الاطلسي يقول
بصراحه ان المطروح ليس هو الطائرات
المقاتله التي تطالب بها اوكرانيا حاليا
بل هي الذخيره هناك مشكله حقيقيه ان وتيره
استعمال الذخيره في هذه الحرب من طرف
الاوكران تفوق بكثير وتيره الانتاج وهذه
مشكله حلف شمال الاطلسي باعتبار انه من
زمان لم يعيش حروبا وان التصنيع تصنيع
الاسلحه
لا يخضع لمساله الاستعجال التي تفرض هذه
الحرب وربما تفرضها مواقف اخرى او انزلاق
معين هذا ما يدركه حلف شمال الاطلسي اليوم
وهذا ما كان على جدول اعمال قمه بروكسيل
الدفاع اليوم هو ان لا يكفي فقط ان تكون
لديك ميزانيه عسكريه لكن كيف ستصرفها اي
ان دول حلف شمال الاطلسي مدعو الى تحريك
التصنيع تصنيع السلاح هي في الحقيقه نحن
نمر الى ما يعرف باقتصاد الحرب في الحقيقه
هو هذه المرحله التي دشن لها ربما هذا
الاجتماع الاستراتيجي يمر الى اقتصاد حرب
بما يعني ذلك من تصنيع وتكثيف
للمخزون الاستراتيجي للحلف ليس فقط في هذه
المواجهه العسكريه لانها تظل مفتوحه على
كل احتمالات شكرا لك على وقفه مع الحدث